Imagine answering your door
and getting a police chase
with your pizza
but it's what the pizza delivery
did that inspired awe,
and he didn't even drop the pizz
Brookhaven, Pennsylvania Police
were chasing
a suspected stolen vehicle
when it went out of control.
The pizza delivery guy took cont
by tripping one of two fleeing s
A 17 year old juvenile
Tyler Morrell from Coco's
Pizza decided to put his foot do
Tyler got a bruise out of it,
but he's been peppered
that pepperoni with praise.
I deliver pizza and bad guys
The suspect
got the Karate Kid treatment
This wasn't the first time
bystanders have given cops a leg
A veteran with a bad back and a
casualty tripped
an armed suspect
being chased by police in Ohio.
Brookhaven police think the pizz
if you're interested in a job,
we are always looking for good p
Those who ordered the pizza
gave a rave review
Tyler didn't just deliver
takeout pizza, he delivered a ta
Jeanne Moos, CNN, New York.